Beyonce and jay-z kicked off their epic
on the run to tour in the UK meanwhile
miss Khloe Kardashian showed up to
support Tristan Thompson at the NBA
Finals and our GG is Zane back on oh my
Yonsei guys Denny here let's not even
waste any time alright because last
night mr. and mrs. Carter kicked off the
sequel to their on the run tour in
Cardiff and let me tell you this show is
bigger than ever
the Carters opened the show descending
hand-in-hand on an elevator platform
looking just straight 100
[Music]
we're not worthy we're not worthy now
the 47 shows run through October and
features one ginormous floating platform
as in it literally floats over the crowd
halfway through the stadium there's also
two catwalks that jut into the audience
17 dancers and get this a 26 percent
orchestra
arranged vertically on stage Pete I'm
excited listen Beyonce's also bringing a
bunch of bootylicious fashion on the
road too now most of us are accustomed
from the house of Geelong she but the
designer behind this show Andy black
bodysuit with a detachable lace in hand
embroidered Krystal skirt is the same
one who designed Megan Markos wedding
dress that's right
truly fit for a queen I'm over here
trying to catch my breath right but at
the center of it all of course is
beyoncé and jay-z's relationship the
good and the bad
the Carters close out the show with
intimate moments from their life
projected on the screen including what
appears to show Beyonce and Jay renewing
their vows
surrounded by Blue Ivy and the twins
roomie and a flower crown and her
brother sir a source exclusively tells
et Beyonce and jay-z wanna let fans into
their lives on their own terms we start
the show as a united front symbolic of
the couple working through their
previous issues but you know what let's
keep it real I'm going for Beyonce I
switching gears now to another woman
sticking by her man Khloe Kardashian she
was spotted out supporting her MBA baby
daddy Tristan Thompson as his team the
Cleveland Cavaliers hit the court for
Game three of the NBA Finals Wednesday
night and check this out it is a pick
snap by Cavs fan Sonny Johnson of his
wife and a fresh-faced Chloe now Sonny a
local basketball coach tells ET Chloe
was all smiles and seemed more than
happy to be at the game to cheer on her
man now it's the first time we've really
seen Chloe publicly support Tristan in
the wake of his alleged cheating scandal
and a source told et Chloe was doing
everything in her power to make this
relationship work adding quote she wants
the whole package and she isn't going to
let Tristan's behavior ruin her lifetime
dream
can't really blame her for that she just
had the baby so I'm rooting for you khlo
but we've got our eyes on another member
of the kardashian-jenner fan her sister
Kendall Jenner Kendall who was recently
linked to NBA star Ben Simmons was
spotted kissing Anwar Hadid
early Tuesday morning he of course is
the kid brother of Kendall's pal Gigi
and Bella but don't get too excited
people
we're told Kendall and Anwar are just
having some fun a source also tells et
that there's actually no awkwardness
with the whole making out with your best
friend's brother thing quote Kendall and
Anwar have known each other for years
and have always been flirtatious and
this is just another sign of that the
two enjoy one another's company and
things could change but for now it's
nothing serious I don't know man it's a
little too incestuous for me like
finding someone else guys
I'm not here for this I shut it down I
don't ship it let me know if you guys
agree meanwhile our Gigi and Zayn back
together
that's what Gigi got fans including me
speculating when she posted this telling
shot to her Instagram stories
it's the 23 year old supermodel lying in
the arms of none other than or
ex-boyfriend mr. Zayn Malik you can't
really see Jane's face there but the
blonde tresses and the arm tattoos are a
tell-all a couple originally confirmed
their split this past March after two
years of dating but something told me
they would eventually find each other
again young love folks all right well
this single person is getting out of
here thank you for watching and make
sure you guys like and comment on this
video and then come back tomorrow
because I've got an interview you're not
gonna want to miss I've already said too
much I gotta go bye